so now the list keeps growing of
democrats pushing back against president
biden's plan to lift title 42 in about
five weeks from yesterday that's the
trump era policy that allows border
agents to turn away migrants due to
covet concerns senator gary peters out
of michigan the latest democrat ranking
ranks
with the white house kellyanne conway
former trump senior adviser mark
panformer clinton pollster advisor nice
to have you both back today um
gary peters isn't just a democratic
senator kellyanne
he runs the democratic senatorial
campaign committee and he says
that these democratic senators are right
to raise questions about changing the
policy
that tells me the polling in these
states must be razor tight for
re-election in november
it is bill and in fact in georgia
arizona nevada wisconsin north carolina
and pennsylvania joe biden's approval
rating is mired in the mid to low 30s
and in maggie hassan's new hampshire
another senator up for reelection who
visited the trump border wall last week
and took pictures joe biden's in the mid
40s so they see that they've got a
president and an unpopular policy here
in revoking title 42 you know the
morning consult poll has been tracking
different biden policy initiatives from
the beginning
and 56 percent oppose
this move by president biden to relax
these border control policies that
president trump implemented this is the
largest backlash we've seen in the
policy in fact a year ago president
biden's approval rating was 58 overall
but it was only 40 percent with respect
to his handling on immigration so this
entire issue border security the drugs
pouring over the southern border the
record number of people coming here this
has been a vexing perplexing issue to
the democrats from the beginning of this
democratic white house and
administration and now he's got people
in his own party running for reelection
in states as diverse as new hampshire
nevada georgia and of course in michigan
where you've got the head of the whole
committee you know bill last point gary
peters michigan is closer much closer to
the canadian border than it is to the
mexican border so he knows what he's
hearing from his constituents in
michigan i think the white house is
making a big mistake not listening to
the public on this and not listening to
members of their own
you get the sense it's going to come to
a head
eventually here mark how do you see you
crunch numbers every day do you agree
with kellyanne or do you see it
otherwise
uh look i think it's not mere
happenstance that
democrats up for election or in swing
areas are saying don't get rid of title
42 i think the the politics and the
polling on this is is extremely clear
i'm intrigued that the administration
didn't so far appeal the transportation
mask mandate and it could be that they
didn't do it so that they can then say
well if there's no mass on planes we can
go ahead with title 42 i don't know why
the administration wants to push title
42 in view of all this and all of this
opposition
certainly they'd be making a mistake i
predict they're going to pull back here
okay all right we'll see if that's the
case i think dana and i on a record
saying the same thing we'll see how it
unfolds another thing here there are 41
percent of americans call for one a
worry about immigration kellyanne that's
the highest rate we have seen now in 11
years
but also in that poll they find
democrats are not worried and that that
shows a clear division among parties as
to how they view the number of people
crossing that border on a daily basis
that's right and in fact the 56 percent
i reference that oppose
biden can pulling back on title 42 it's
60 percent support among democrats only
8 among republicans and 31
among independents which shows you the
independents are really aligning with
republicans on this but bill i don't
understand
why this white house is not paying more
attention to the public they can't even
take a win on yesterday's judicial
announcement that you no longer have to
wear masks instead of saying well let's
see they should be taking a win they
should they should not be taking the joy
away from the public and on this issue
of immigration i think they all look at
it through the donald trump lens and
that's a mistake they say you know trump
bad we're good trump's wall we tear it
down spite is no way to run a country
and this is why his own democratic base
the democratic senators excuse me are
turning on him a little bit he's really
taken incoming i'd be very con i'd be
very
curious to see what senator maggie
hassan who won by .14 percent last time
she won by 1 000 votes in 2016. if she
welcomes biden's visit today fentanyl is
the number one killer 18 to 44 year olds
in this country including in her home
state of new hampshire
interesting to watch mark last point on
this we are often the only network
that covers the border issue
no one else is there and if they are
their stories aren't on the air mark
well it's the number three issue if you
look at issues it's the economy it's the
virus it's immigration and then
typically healthcare and so other
networks should be covering it although
i i agree with kellyanne it's mostly
animating republican voters not
democratic voters in terms of the way it
plays out but then most voters grossly
underestimate by a factor of 10 how many
people are really crossing the border
interesting mark thanks mark penn and
kellyanne conway great pairing thanks
for coming back this week and we'll talk
again next week
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now